it's complicated that's a description
that applies to a lot of activity in and
around washington these days
but especially applies to one of the
most important relationships president
joe biden is working on
his long acquaintance with israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu
these two leaders have been joined anew
in recent days of course by the rising
tensions between israelis and
palestinians
and specifically the outbreak of
violence between israel and hamas forces
in the gaza strip
president biden and prime minister
netanyahu have talked numerous times
during the course of this crisis
and publicly mr biden has largely
defended israel's right to respond with
military force
to hamas rocket attacks saying it was
entitled to act in self-defense
the united states fully supports
israel's right to defend itself
against indiscriminate rocket attacks
from hamas
and other gaza-based terrorist groups
that have taken the lives of innocent
civilians
in israel privately he reportedly has
been much tougher with mr netanyahu
saying he expected him to de-escalate
the situation
and deal with palestinian grievances his
nudging may have led to the ceasefire
that's finally taken hold
but these two are far from done with
each other now the biden administration
inevitably will be deeply involved in
trying to broker a broader agreement to
simultaneously deal with israel's
security concerns
as well as palestinians simmering anger
at the way they're treated by israel
not just in gaza but also in the west
bank and jerusalem and increasingly
inside israel itself the long history of
this relationship shows president biden
is prepared to push prime minister
netanyahu to go further than he wants
to accommodate palestinian demands but
also that he's more likely to do his
hard pressing privately
rather than publicly i don't talk about
what i tell people in private
i don't talk about what we negotiate in
private these two men have known each
other since the early 1980s when mr
netanyahu was the second in charge at
the israeli embassy in washington
and then later israel's ambassador to
the united nations
mr biden meanwhile was a u.s senator
developing a particular interest
in foreign affairs they came into closer
contact in the 1990s when mr netanyahu
became prime minister and senator biden
was on his way
to becoming the top democrat and
eventually chairman of the senate
foreign relations committee
they were in these positions of power in
the early 2000s when the george w
bush administration was both marshaling
an international response to the 9 11
terrorist
attacks and also trying to get peace
talks going between israel and the
palestinians
their relationship became more important
during the obama administration
when mr biden was vice president and mr
netanyahu again
became prime minister their relationship
also became more tense in those days
the obama administration put a high
priority on finding a new
israeli-palestinian peace accord vice
president biden was visiting israel in
march 2010
trying to assure israel of american
support for its security in any such
peace deal
when the netanyahu administration
announced the construction of hundreds
of new housing units for jews in east
jerusalem
the part of the city where palestinians
envisioned putting the capital of a
palestinian state someday
israeli housing there is one of the most
sensitive issues for palestinians
and one that u.s officials have long
thought undermines the chances for
diplomacy
mr biden was blindsided and he wasn't
happy
there were tensions again on another
front in 2015
when prime minister netanyahu visited
washington and at the invitation of
republican leaders
delivered a speech to a joint session of
congress devoted to attacking the iran
nuclear deal
the obama administration was then
negotiating
the greatest danger facing our world
is the marriage of militant islam with
nuclear weapons
to defeat isis and let iran get nuclear
weapons
would be to win the battle but lose the
war
we can't let that happen
obama administration officials were
furious and vice president biden
who normally would have attended such a
speech was notably absent
through these tensions president biden
and prime minister netanyahu appear to
have maintained a good relationship
one in which they are generally
supportive of each other publicly
but have blunt and sometimes acrimonious
conversations in private
mr biden in particular seems to have
decided to avoid the public sparring
that hurt president obama's relationship
with israel
these two men are now being tested anew
as it is it may be that their
relationship is shored up by one
characteristic that they share
both joe biden and benjamin netanyahu
are very good
at the art of political survival